[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin guten abend ihnen allen
sportliche später wieder mit kristin
otto die leichtathletik werden beginnt
guten abend alles wichtige an diesem
freitag in den nächsten 20 minuten unter
anderem mit diesen themen
streit ums booster der
gesundheitsminister empfiehlt die vierte
impfung auch für unter 60 jährige die
impfkommission hält dagegen
schwierige partnerschaft us präsident
biden besucht saudi arabien und trifft
dort auch den umstrittenen kronprinzen
und heldensagen ganz anders die
nibelungen festspiele beginnen diesmal
geben die frauen den ton an
ganz anders als letzten und vorletzten
sommer haben wir dieses mal in
deutschland ziemlich hohe corona
instanzen aktuell liegt sie bundesweit
offiziell bei 700 19,2 auch die
situation auf intensivstationen gibt
anlass zur sorge deswegen und mit blick
auf herbst und winter empfiehlt
gesundheitsminister lauterbach jetzt
auch allen unter 60 jährigen eine vierte
impfung widerspruch kommt von der
impfkommission britta spiekermann
berichtet
minister lauterbach auf dem weg zu einer
empfehlung nicht ganz neu und hoch
umstritten er rät zur vierten impfung
auch für unter 60 jährige bei den unter
60-jährigen muss es jeder selbst
entscheiden in absprache mit dem
hausarzt da wäre es insbesondere für
diejenigen eine überlegung wert die
viele kontakte haben und einen
sorgenfreien sommer durch leben wollen
und sich zum beispiel auch vor longo
wird besser schützen wollen widerspruch
kommt von der eigentlich zuständigen
impfkommission es gebe keine daten die
lauterbachs imf ratschlag rechtfertigen
sagt stiko chef thomas mertens ich halte
es für schlecht medizinischer
empfehlungen unter dem motto viel hilft
viel auszusprechen seine kommission
empfiehlt über 70-jährige frau erkrankte
und pflegepersonal das vierte mal zu
impfen und bleibt auch jetzt dabei
minister und stiko überkreuz dafür gibt
es viel kopfschütteln und einen rat auch
ich eine vierte empfangen möchte oder
nicht hängt ja auch ein bisschen davon
ab wie hoch ist mein persönliche
sicherheitsbedürfnis kurz nach einer
vierten impfung hat man sicherlich in
zusätzlichen schutz laut intensiv
register ist die bettenbelegung leicht
angestiegen priorität habe die impfung
älterer menschen so wie es die ständige
impfkommission fordert das heißt auf
jeden fall die empfehlung einer erde
vierten impfung für alle die über 70
sind oder die eben entsprechende
zusätzliche erkrankungen
haben hier sind impfungen wirklich
dringend empfohlen das
gesundheitsministerium verspricht für
september speziell an virusvarianten
angepasste impfstoffe dieser zeitplan
ist allerdings ohne gewähr
zum abschluss seiner nahost reise ist us
präsident biden in saudi-arabien
eingetroffen der besuch gilt als heikel
vor allem weil er den umstrittenen
kronprinzen mohammed ins all man trifft
der steht im verdacht den mord am
saudischen journalisten cascioli in
auftrag gegeben zu haben vor vier jahren
im saudischen konsulat in istanbul und
wird deshalb von westlichen politikern
gemieden wir sprechen jetzt mit el mati
wissen im saudi arabischen dschiddah
elmar welche interessen in saudi arabien
steht für den us präsidenten offenbar
höher als der moralische konflikte im
fall kvg
ganz große strategische interessen sonst
würde ja die begrüßung vorhin übrigens
per faust nicht mehr handschlag würde
dennoch in die geschichte eingehen als
politischer sieg für mohammed bin salman
und als krachende niederlage für die
beiden deswegen muss er was mitbringen
und es geht ihm um große dinge einmal
ein arabisch israelisches bündnis gegen
den iran da ist im grunde genommen die
saudische zusage dass flugzeuge aus
israel jetzt hier noch saudi arabien
fliegen können eigentlich nur der
auftakt zum zweiten geht es um eine
massive ausdehnung der öl fördermengen
um eben den druck auf den
internationalen energiemärkten
abzufedern und das dritte ist ein ausbau
massiver ausbau auch der
wirtschaftlichen und technologischen
zusammenarbeit mit den golfstaaten dem
us-präsidenten geht es dabei auch um
gegenzuhalten gegen den immer wachsenden
einfluss von china hier in dieser region
deswegen will diese enge zusammenarbeit
stichwort kann gegen den autoritär ismus
aber wenn er den wirklich ernst meint
dann müsste er hier auch konkrete
zusagen einfordern in den sachen
menschen und bürgerrechten von saudi
arabien
wenn er das nicht tut zu sagen kritiker
dann wäre das ein bankrott seiner
aussenpolitik el mati wissen vielen dank
nach jeder der tonys angekommen das bild
nicht immer und das bitten wir zu
entschuldigen
schon vor seiner weiterreise nach saudi
arabien hatte biden in bethlehem im
westjordanland palästinenserpräsident
abbas getroffen er sicherte den
palästinensern rund 300 millionen dollar
an weiteren finanzhilfen zu und
wiederholte seine unterstützung für
einen unabhängigen palästinenserstaat
eine zeitnahe wiederaufnahme der
friedensgespräche mit israel sieht der
us präsident allerdings nicht
jetzt zum krieg in der ukraine der
russische angriff auf die stadt wie
nizza gestern hat scharfe reaktionen
ausgelöst die bundesregierung sprach von
einem akt der grausamkeit gegen die
zivilbevölkerung
russland hat inzwischen eingeräumt das
gebäude in venetien mit
marschflugkörpern geschossen zu haben
dort hätten sich militärs getroffen die
ukraine weist das zurück bei dem angriff
wurden mindestens 23 menschen getötet
unter ihnen drei kinder
im kriegsgebiet tobt ein zäher kampf um
jedes dorf um jede straße unser reporter
dara hassanzadeh konnte eine ukrainische
patrouille begleiten in der nähe der
stadt katif
die front knapp 20 kilometer vortrag
büffel haben das dorf russkaja so war
erobert entlaufen aus dem zerbombten zog
kommandant sehr wohl ott ist zu diesem
frontabschnitt verantwortlich der
50-jährige ist eigentümer des größten
agrarunternehmens der ukraine
bewirtschaftet 75.000 hektar land 30
davon hat russland besetzt
wir haben ein starkes team von
ausbildern die unsere offiziere
trainieren und auch soldaten die seit
2014 im einsatz waren im sonntaz krieg
schlechtes wetter bedeutet schlechte
sicht für russische aufklärungsdrohnen
und weniger gefahr für die patrouille
sie konnten das dorf zurück erobern und
halten ihre bunker wechseln sie
regelmäßig und finden immer wieder
russische hinterlassenschaften
wir sie vermisst ist überall hier in
jedem haus
die russische armee weiß dass jedem tal
sind es ist ein tödliches katz und
mausspiel drohnen und artillerie gegen
ortskenntnis und beweglichkeit
die menschen wollen nicht mehr in der
vergangenheit leben die menschen wollen
eine zukunft haben und die zukunft das
ist eine normale freie demokratische
welt eine freie ukraine frei vom
balanstr so viel zeit
ihre einheit muss hier der russischen
armee stand halten sonst könnte ihr tal
ein einfallstor nach hagel werden
ein nachbarland der ukraine die republik
moldau versorgt besonders viele
geflüchtete um diese und andere
kriegsfolgen abzumildern will die
internationale gemeinschaft dem land mit
600 millionen euro helfen
außenministerin baerbock hat in bukarest
77 millionen euro deutschen anteil
zugesagt das geld soll unter anderem
hohe energiepreise abfedern und in die
flüchtlingshilfe fließen
wird russland auch nach der wartung von
nord stream 1 weiter gas nach
deutschland leiten und falls nicht droht
dann ein gas notstand die sorgen sind
groß aber in diesem zusammenhang ist es
wichtig zu wissen wie hoch die
abhängigkeit zu russland noch ist wie
voll unsere gasspeicher aktuell sind und
welche strategien verfolgen soll
elisabeth schmidt jetzt mit einer
standortbestimmung
er herrscht weiter über die deutschen
gaslieferungen seit montag fließt nicht
nur über 90 m 1 kein erdgas mehr nach
deutschland auch bei den anderen
russischen pipelines ist die liefermenge
gleich null also insofern kann es
durchaus auch kalkül sein dass man schon
jetzt an droht das danach nach der
erwartung kein erdgas mehr geliefert
wird eine drohung doch deutschlands
abhängigkeit von russland nimmt ab mitte
märz waren die gasspeicher nur zu 24
prozent gefüllt mittlerweile sind es
rund 65 prozent deutlich mehr als vor
einem jahr doch wie die russischen
lieferungen ersetzen norwegen und die
niederlande haben ihre export
kapazitäten erreicht nord stream 1 nicht
liefert nach der wartung können wir
eigentlich nichts anderes machen außer
zu sparen das heißt weniger erdgas zu
verbrauchen zu jahresbeginn bezog
deutschland noch 55 prozent seines
erdgases aus russland laut einer studie
aus brüssel beträgt die abhängigkeit
heute nur noch 29 prozent weil erdgas
teuer zugekauft wurde aus norwegen oder
den niederlanden und weil industrie und
haushalte etwa zehn prozent erdgas
eingespart haben es fehlen aber noch 29
prozent wenn wir das alles verteilen nur
auf die haushaltskunden in deutschland
dann würden leute erfrieren wenn wir das
aber eben breit verteilt zwischen den
verschiedenen sektoren in deutschland
und auch in europa dann dass es keine
stromausfälle geben dann muss niemand
erfrieren und dann läuft auch die
wirtschaft großenteils weiter verteilen
lautet das stichwort innerhalb der eu
innerhalb deutschlands die
erdgaslieferungen und die
sparanstrengungen von moskau unabhängig
werden ist möglich aber es wird
milliarden kosten
wegen steigender energiekosten und der
hohen inflation will arbeitsminister
heil menschen mit kleinen einkommen noch
mehr unterstützen sein ziel sei es die
regelsätze für hartz 4 im nächsten jahr
deutlich zu erhöhen sagte der
spd-politiker dem redaktions netzwerk
deutschland zuspruch gibt es von den
gewerkschaften widerspruch vom
regierungspartner fdp mit verweis auf
den koalitionsvertrag
es gibt wieder ein neues zdf
politbarometer mit sehr interessanten
ergebnissen matthias fornoff ist wieder
bei uns halo matthias alle genannt was
sagen denn die bürgerinnen und bürger zu
den aktuellen regierungsmaßnahmen in
dieser krise naja tank rabatt
energiepreis pauschalen euro ticket es
ist schon einiges passiert zur
entlastung der bürger da muss aber noch
mehr kommen finden die befragten
die maßnahmen sind ausreichend sagen 20
prozent gut drei viertel aber finden das
reicht nicht
die sorgen nehmen zu und das schlägt
sich nieder in der bewertung der
politiker für die schlechtere bewertung
im vergleich zur umfrage vor zwei wochen
steht der rote pfeil die verluste
deutlich am meisten verliert
finanzminister lindner die hochzeits
sause auf sylt nehmen ihm offenbar viele
übel matthias viele müssen in der
aktuellen situation den gürtel enger
schnallen auch mit blick auf herbst und
winter wie sieht es da mit der
solidarität für die ukraine aus trotz
der preis explosion ist weiter eine
deutliche mehrheit dafür die ukraine zu
unterstützen 70 prozent sehen das so 22
prozent nicht mehrheiten dafür bei den
anhängern aller parteien außer bei denen
der afd
ein kurzer blick nach aufs
kräfteverhältnis der parteien wenn am
sonntag bundestagswahl wäre käme die spd
auf 21 prozent die union 26 - einst im
vergleich zu anfang juli grüne 25 fdp 6
afd 11 prozent plus 1 und linke 5
prozent relativ wenig bewegung also in
diesen bewegten zeiten dann vielen dank
matthias und wie immer das ausführliche
zdf politbarometer das gibt es dann wie
gewohnt ab 22 uhr im heute-journal oder
jederzeit zum nachlesen auf zdf heute.de
oder in unserer web
der fall schlug ziemlich hohe wellen ein
bundeswehroffizier gibt sich als
syrischer flüchtlinge aus und hat
offenbar terroranschläge geplant aus
rechtsextremen motiven
heute wurde franco a deswegen vom
oberlandesgericht frankfurt zu über fünf
jahren haft verurteilt isabel de la vega
es ist das ende eines ungewöhnlichen
prozesses frank ua ein offizier der
bundeswehr wird verurteilt wegen planung
einer schweren staatsgefährdenden
straftat ich ps als wichtigen erfolg in
der bekämpfung des rechtsextremismus
rassismus und antisemitismus in der
bundesrepublik deutschland an januar
2017 am flughafen wien entdeckt eine
reinigungskraft eine pistole versteckt
auf der toilette als franco a sie
abholen will wird er festgenommen und
dann machen die beamten eine
überraschende entdeckung die
fingerabdrücke des festgenommenen
passend zum oberleutnant franco a und
zum syrischen flüchtlingen david
benjamin der offizier hatte mit einer
falschen identität bei den deutschen
behörden asyl beantragt mit erfolg über
ein jahr führte frank ua ein doppelleben
als offizier eines jägerbataillons und
als flüchtlinge aus syrien nach seiner
festnahme wurden dutzende sprachmemos
mit rechtsextremistischen inhalten
gesichert vor gericht gab er zu sich
waffen und munition besorgt zu haben und
es gab todes listen mit namen von
politikern
frank o a hat kein geständnis abgelegt
dennoch folgten die richter weitgehend
der staatsanwaltschaft den die ziehen
kette hat eindeutig gezeigt dass franco
asien waffen besorgt hat tatorte
ausgekundschaftet hat schießen geübt hat
und das ganze mit dem ziel prominente
und politiker zu ermorden die in seinen
augen flüchtlings freundlich waren frank
o a ist zu fünfeinhalb jahren haft
verurteilt worden die verteidigung will
nun revision beantragen
etwa 30 millionen fahrgäste nutzen das
neun euro ticket ende august läuft die
aktion aus und geht es nach den
verkehrsunternehmen soll es weiter eine
verbilligte monatskarte für busse und
bahnen geben ihr vorschlag
69 euro im monat weiter gültig für den
gesamten pnv in deutschland
in den südeuropäischen urlaubsländer
wüten in ausgetrockneten gegenden immer
mehr brände betroffen ist auch die
französische atlantikküste südwestlich
von bordeaux
10.000 menschen wurden dort in
sicherheit gebracht wind fachte die
flammen immer wieder an und treibt sie
in richtung bewohnte gebiete teilweise
dauert es tage bis die feuer
kontrolliert oder eingedämmt werden
können
in der nibelungensage ist siegfried der
tragische held ist wissen sie bewundert
von seiner frau kriemhild und gehasst
von grün hält also soweit der klassische
stoff dass man diese geschichte auch
völlig anders erzählen kann zeigen ab
heute die nibelungen festspiele in worms
diesmal verbünden sich die beiden
rivalinnen gegen das kriegerische
treiben der männer und das in
spektakulärer kulisse überall wasser
spiegelungen monitore christopher heinze
über das mittelalter epos der deutschen
in ganz neuer form
ein großer pool als bühne der eine
flusslandschaft darstellt schauspieler
die ständig im un unter wasser sind
diesmal ist alles anders als sonst
müssen extrem große herausforderung also
ist auch interessant wie der körper
reagiert man trocknet wahnsinnig aus ich
glaube die ersten wochen war er hatte
ich kann ich gar nicht durch meine augen
gucken weil diese geschwollen waren also
ja es macht spaß aber es ist auch echt
ganz schön anstrengend und
herausfordernd
im mittelpunkt der uraufführung
heldensaga einen königin drama zwei
kämpferische frauen brünhild und
kriemhild
es wird geliebt gemobbt gemordet der
nibelungen herrscher wird zum hampelmann
und die frauen machen gemeinsame sache
statt sich gegeneinander ausspielen zu
lassen
es geht um uns sehr stark feministischen
einschlag also wirklich auf die
fragestellung regieren frauen die welt
anders also gehen frau und anders mit
macht mit egoismus mit politikum das ist
schon ein stück zur zeit also seid
wirklich mit feminismus zu tun mit
diversität zu tun vor allem auch mit
krieg wotan vater der brünnhilde gibt
dem stück das böse mit aktuellen bezügen
wendet immer alles in den krieg egal wie
man es dreht und wendet das solltet ihr
doch wissen die diesjährigen nibelungen
festspiele spektakulär spannend und
zugleich auf höhe der zeit
ja und diese nibelungen version noch zu
sehen bis zum 31 juli vor dem dom zu
worms und jetzt zu den deutschen
fußballerinnen christine gute stimmung
bei der em das viertelfinale ist er
bereits sicher im letzten gruppenspiel
gegen finnland werden morgen abend live
hier bei uns im zdf für die zetas rauch
und lena oberdorf da gelbgesperrt fehlen
wieder fit und definitiv dabei die
chefin martina voss tecklenburg
im gestrigen training wurde die
bundestrainerin durch ihre assistentin
ersetzt kein grund zur sorge heute gab
sie entwarnung mir geht es gut ich hatte
nur eine migräne das haben viele andere
menschen auch also alles alles gute wird
ja gut behandelt finnland bisher ohne
punktgewinn
dabei soll es auch bleiben hofft die
wieder erstarkte bundestrainerin für uns
gilt einfach weiter diesen flow zu
halten diese energie aufrechtzuerhalten
ein gutes spiel zu machen diese positive
stimmung auch für uns zu nutzen die
jubelt uhr soll weiter gehen am liebsten
noch bis nach dem finale schön wär's mit
dem sieg für mats petersen endete die 13
etappe der tour de france nach gut 190
kilometern löste sich der däne auf der
zielgeraden in saint-etienne mit dem
stärksten antritt aus dem führenden trio
sicherte dänemark den dritten
tageserfolg unverändert in gelb sein
landsmann jonas weingart simon geschke
fährt auch morgen im bergtrikot den
fünften tag nacheinander so oft wie kein
anderer deutscher radprofi zuvor also
ein rekord
erstmalig in den usa in eugene werden
von heute an leichtathletik
weltmeisterschaften ausgetragen und
gleich mit deutschen medaillenchancen
über 20 kilometer gehen
christopher linke aus potsdam war
vierter bei der vorangegangenen wm in
doha sein aussichtsreicher wettkampf
startet kurz nach mitternacht die wm in
eugene im us bundesstaat oregon
verabschiedet am abend eine besondere
sportlerin erlös und felix 36 jahre alt
sieben mal olympia-gold 13 wm-titel
letzte medaillenjagd die 4 x 400 meter
mixed staffel für mich schließt sich
hier zu hause nun der kreis das wird
wirklich sehr sehr speziell werden
christian schwandt erster starter des
dsv teams ist schon ausgeschieden in der
hammerwurf qualifikation
und mehr zur leichtathletik-wm in einer
stunde im livestream unter sportstudio
de einfach machen schon einfach mal
sagen christine zum wetter von uns so
viel am wochenende meist sommerlich warm
im norden auch wolken und vielleicht ein
bisschen regen gleich mehr von katja
horneffer das heute journal mit bettina
schausten startet um 22 uhr morgen ist
barbara hahlweg hier für sie schönen
dank für das interesse und einen schönen
start ins wochenende machen sie es gut
[Musik]
guten abend vielleicht haben sie sich
heute auch über etwas regen hier in
norddeutschland gefreut jetzt kommt ein
neues tieferen und das bringt auch regen
netz in der ersten nachthälfte regnet
ist vor allen dingen an der nordseeküste
im laufe der zweiten nachthälfte zieht
der regen weiter ostwärts da kann auch
mal ein gewitter dabei sein südlich der
nördlichen mittelgebirge bleibt es
trocken temperaturen sinken auf 14 grad
in der lüneburger heide oder am
niederrhein und bis 6 grad in der
oberpfalz morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen an der see bei 17 bis
20 grad sonst werden 20 bis 24 in bayern
baden-württemberg in teilen von hessen
in rheinland pfalz und dem saarland
sommerliche 25 bis 29 grad erreicht
morgen vormittag kann es hier im osten
noch letzte regenschauer und gewitter
geben die dann rasch nach osten abziehen
bei einem recht kräftigen wind aus
nordwestlichen richtungen sonst ist es
mal mehr mal weniger stark bewölkt und
am sonnigsten wird zwischen dem
karwendel und dem oberhalb am sonntag
gibt es in süddeutschland noch mehr
sonne bei temperaturen von 26 bis 32
grad im norden ist es stärker bewölkt
und dann kommt die hitze mit bis zu 41
grad am dienstag rechnen wir heute guten
abend